[Music]
um
next question question number five
for what reason will vabillon receive
got seven last play
well the reason is in uh verse two
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of wrath of fornication now if
you go to uh
uh revelation 14 verse nine and the
third angels follow them say without
voice if any man worship the beast and
his image and receive his mark in his
forehead in his hand the same shall
drink of the wine of the wrath of god
which is poured out without mixture into
the cup of his indignation this means
this by the way revelation 49-11 the
most frightful uh statement in the
entire bible let me say it again not
even the third of genesis chapter seven
and eight and nine eighty or seven and
eight it is the proclamation of
revelation 14 9-11 because god pours out
his wrath without mercy why if any man
worship the beast and his image we know
the beast is the the people system an
image is a system set up that reflects
the beast and part of that will be
apostate protestantism but god says
anyone who accepts that system of error
i will pour out upon you my it is he
doesn't help my worst judgment of those
who rob banks even though that's bad or
steal cars or whatever he's dealing with
those who have made religious choices in
direct opposition to thus save the lord
those who have set aside god's law for a
man-made law they received the worst of
god's punishment and so the reason that
god's anger is poured out and his anger
is righteous it is because a system has
replaced him and the bible speaks of
abomination the bible has sins then it
has abominations abomination is a
concentrated form of sin that makes god
funded and the one that does that is
idolatry where you put someone else in
god's place and babylon has done that
and the beast that people worship and
the image of the beast that people will
worship these take god's place in
people's lives and god will pour out his
worst and most ah most painful
punishment but it will still be an act
of righteousness
promoting
error and blinding people deceiving
people will be the reason babylon will
receive god's destructive justice
amen
um
the truth make us free the the truth uh
open our eyes yes tell us to improve our
lives but this other system is trying to
put us down to deceive us to actually
kill us and god doesn't want that god
want us to be happy to be complete to be
whole
one of the ways to deceive people is to
withhold certain information from them
i mean governments do it corporations do
it business some churches do it just
with some information
but jesus said all things that i've
heard of my father i have made known
unto you god doesn't hide what we need
he doesn't do that he said if it were
not so i would have told you that's the
way jesus functions he tells you what
you need to know to keep people in error
you have to hide the truth from them you
hide the truth you deliberately hide the
truth and the result is error deception
and that's what babylon has been doing
and is doing and god has to put a stop
to that
amen thank you pastor they are there
there are preachers in sunday churches
who know if they're listening to me now
they know the sabbath is saturday sunset
friday to sunset saturday and they will
not preach it because they don't want to
lose the congregation and the offering
but they know the sabbath is saturday
but they will not appreciate it and if
they're listening to me they ought to
have the courage with god's help to come
out and say the seventh day is the
sabbath even if you lose your church
lose your church but don't lose heaven
never contribute to someone's
destruction contribute to someone's
salvation and the promotion of error is
an unforgivable contribution to
someone's destruction
wow that's definitely not love in your
neighbor withholding